the best moment the best moment of my
life was in court when the guy says the
United States vs jonh staliano and are
still eight john Stagliano they
mispronounce me john Stagliano i'm
thinking wow i have achieved something
in my life hi I'm Nick Gillespie with
reason TV and today I'm sitting with
John staliano
who's the head of evil angel productions
a pornography production and
distribution company we're talking to
you right now because you're in DC for a
very particular reason explain why
you're here well the Justice Department
has decided to bring an obscenity
prosecution against me for selling to
movies and also for having a trailer on
my website evil angel calm that is
theoretically available for minors to
look at after they've jumped through
some hoops and whatever
they could look at this particular
trailer and they're saying that that is
obscene I should add before we go on
that John you have contributed to Reason
Foundation the nonprofit that publishes
Reason magazine reason online and reason
TV that's correct and I was selling
reason on UCLA campus in 1972 in the
fall did you sell many copies I sold a
few I sold about 40 or 50 dollars worth
on I didn't actually pay reason back
until about 15 years later well I needed
an have in the meantime what are the two
titles that you are being charged with
obscenity the two movies are Milton
tempos and storms quarters - target
practice John for somebody who is not a
who is either not interested in
pornography or things that porn is
offensive can you what would you say to
them
terms of how what you're doing is really
a case of free expression white
everybody who believes in freedom should
really be interested in the outcome of
your case being an acquittal the reason
why I think this case is important is
because it's it's another area where the
government thinks they should be able to
run our lives and this is certainly an
important area where it's art that we
consume it's recreation that we consume
and it's the principle that the
government can come in and say behave
this way and they could easily extend
that from looking at porn to consuming
fast foods to smoking cigarettes oh they
already did that to all sorts of things
and every anything that's that can
develop a constituency for people to
want other people to behave in that way
is now open in this society where the
majority can impose its standards and
behavior patterns upon a minority and
that's a very bad precedent to set and
we've already said it in this country
and it's getting worse you are going to
be mounting into fence I mean you you
today you were arraigned and you entered
Ashley what pleaded you not guilty and
not guilty of obscenity that's correct
and so we everybody is clear of
obscenity is a type of expression which
is not covered under the First Amendment
so the issue is really whether or not
the court or a jury and will define your
films as obscene
that's correct okay and the current
guidelines for the determining obscenity
come out of a Supreme Court case from
the early seventies Miller in which
Justice Warren burger the Chief Justice
at the time came up with
the three-part guideline and he said the
basic guidelines for the Trier of fact
must be first whether the average person
applying contemporary community
standards would find that the work taken
as a whole appeals to the prurient
interest second whether the work depicts
or describes in patently in a patently
offensive way sexual conduct
specifically defined by the applicable
state law as it seemed and see whether
the work taken as a whole again lacks
serious or literary artistic political
or scientific value you are going to be
arguing that your material is not in
fact obscene well there are several
things that we're going to be arguing
one of the things is that that in fact
this stuff is out there in the community
both the milk [ __ ] type movies and
the sporting type movies are prevalent
in adult video stores throughout the
area here in Washington DC this is not a
conservative area for selling movies
it's also true and and we're thinking
about doing an argument like this is
that DVD sales are going down rather
rapidly right now and people are
consuming their pornography on the
Internet right and on the Internet it's
a vastly different world where there's
lots of different things available and
the community standard of the Internet
is very different the other thing is
when this Miller case came down in 1973
pornography if it was gonna be shown
anywhere was gonna be in a theater which
would be on a public street in
somebody's small town or in somebody's
big city or whatever where everybody
could drive by the marquee and see that
it's there and their children could see
this there and everything would be out
in the open the name of the movie beyond
their marquee and that's a way way
different world than what we have today
where people consume pornography in the
privacy of their own homes more and more
so just on their computers and and and
it's not in the public space at all when
it's there and and this is a completely
different world and the applicable law
at the
does not apply now to today's world but
then in the Miller case there is the
question of whether the work taken as a
whole like serious literary artistic
political or scientific value will you
be challenging that how do you define
art I mean art I think good art
hits you below the the cerebral cortex
but like right there in the the
brainstem or whatever he says oh I like
that you know and seeing a beautiful
round ass is very artistic and it hits
people it's like whoa that's like you
know I like ass but that's like a
beautiful ass so by definition you've
selected something really beautiful of
that genre and that's art you do
artistic selection the real key here is
this is a way for the average guy alone
at home to get off or girl I've known a
lot of girls that are in this stuff like
this especially the squirting stuff
because that focus is on female orgasm
and so it's a real prejudice movie I
mean you know male orgasm is all over
porno movies female orgasm is not but
the trailer was made by belladonna and
the thing is pornography is the way for
people with less money and less power to
get off if you've got lots of money if
you've got prestige if you are a king or
a nobleman a couple hundred years ago or
today you're like a high-priced lawyer
or a congressman or a senator or a
governor of New York you can afford call
girls you can get off you can have your
sexual desire satisfied but if you're a
normal working guy you can't afford that
and this is what you get off on and this
is what your pleasure is and that's what
the government wants to suppress and
that to me is just rotten let's just you
know kick the mother excuse me the
bastards out but it's not going to
happen because they're the ones will
controlling us you a very much belief in
privacy right you very much
I mean you don't want to flaunt things
in people's faces
yeah I'm not I'm not the kind of guy
that does I'm not a big exhibitionist at
all I think that you know some people
don't like porno and it should not be in
their faces I've always been very
uncomfortable with with with some people
who make porno movies that want to say
oh this is free speech you know and I'm
out there and I'm just talking about it
all the time
That's not me you know I make my porno
movies for the people that love porno
they're my fans they're other people I
make it for for some other people that
want to have to get more publicity and
stuff that's not interesting to me I
don't want porno to be in the face of
people that don't want to see it